His tenure as Tony Stark may have come to
an end, but the MCU has left Robert Downey
Jr. with the kind of professional resources
he'd never had before in his career, from
a massive worldwide fanbase to a hefty bank
account to the kind of clout in Hollywood
that will allow him to pursue a host of new
projects.
Here's why he left the MCU, and what's ahead
for Marvel's first leading man.
Getting off the MCU "bus"
First thing's first: Why did Downey and his
fellow Avenger Chris Evans elect to leave
the MCU in the first place?
Disney Twenty-Three magazine has the answer.
In a recent chat with the insider outlet,
the iconic Iron Man actor said their time
was simply up, saying,
"We had to get off.
We opted to, and knew it was part of the job
to get off the bus while it rolled on to other
destinations.
There’s something very sobering about it.
I’m glad he and I will be there to welcome
others as they retire their jerseys."
"No amount of money ever bought a second of
time."
"Smart guy."
As for his legacy in the MCU, RDJ was his
usual charming and self-effacing self, saying,
"I really don’t need to look any farther
than my co-stars.
Mark Ruffalo is an activist, Chris Evans is
a diehard American and proponent of true democracy.
I don’t really have the gumption, the skill
set, the drive, or the humility either of
those guys do."
His modesty is sweet, but MCU fans will always
love RDJ 3000, and will keep their fingers
crossed for a cameo or two as the Marvel machine
moves on without him.
The Voyage of Doctor Dolittle
Two major film adaptations of Hugh Lofting's
Doctor Dolittle novels have already been released,
including Eddie Murphy's famously broad take
on the character.
Now it's Downey's turn to take on the role
of an eccentric animal expert who's able to
talk to his animal friends.
Downey has been attached to the project since
the spring of 2017, and principal photography
on the film began the following year, but
then the production hit a snag.
In April of 2019, it was reported that producers
had serious concerns about the initial cut
of the film.
After some rewrites and much reported tweaking,
the studio pushed back the film's release
date from summer 2019 to January 17, 2020.
In addition to Downey in the title role, The
Voyage of Doctor Dolittle will feature an
all-star cast of celebrity voices for animals,
including Spider-Man himself, Tom Holland.
Sherlock Holmes 3
Shortly after he began his cinematic journey
as Tony Stark, Robert Downey Jr. took on another
iconic character: Sherlock Holmes.
Downey played the legendary detective in two
action-heavy films in 2009 and 2011, which
grossed more than $1 billion worldwide combined.
The Sherlock Holmes films were directed by
Guy Ritchie and packed top-tier talent into
their casts, including Jude Law as Dr. Watson.
In the spring of 2018, Warner Bros.
Pictures finally announced a third film in
the series featuring the return of Downey
in the title role and Law as Watson.
We know very little about the film, which
was originally set to be released on Christmas
Day, 2020, but has since been pushed back
to December 21, 2021.
This new date places the sequel's release
ten years after its predecessor, Sherlock
Holmes: A Game of Shadows.
The project does not yet have an announced
director, which means there's a chance Ritchie
could also return.
Dr. John Brinkley biopic
In 2017, it was announced that Downey would
star in an upcoming film based on an episode
of the Reply All podcast.
The episode, titled "Man of the People," was
the story of John Brinkley, a doctor who rose
to fame and fortune in the early 20th century
for a number of strange and controversial
"medical" procedures, including transplanting
goat testicles into humans.
As dramatized in the 2016 Brinkley documentary
Nuts!, the pioneering doc used radio as a
way to reach the masses.
Downey will reportedly star in the film as
Brinkley, putting him in a great position
to use his charm onscreen for a conman role.
Richard Linklater will direct, while Downey
and his wife Susan will produce through their
Team Downey production banner.
The film does not yet have a release date.
All-Star Weekend
Downey has great comedy chops, something we've
known about him since the early days of his
career when he was playing supporting roles
in John Hughes films like Weird Science.
"This is Max.
We call him Mad Max."
He's gotten more recent opportunities to show
off those skills thanks to films like Chef
and Due Date.
Sometime soon, he'll be flexing his comedy
muscles in a big way yet again with a role
in All-Star Weekend, the directorial debut
of his The Soloist co-star Jamie Foxx.
Foxx is the writer, director, and star of
the film, which follows two friends as they
try to make it from their home in Indiana
to the NBA All-Star Game in Los Angeles while
constantly battling each other as fans of
LeBron James and Steph Curry, respectively.
All-Star Weekend does not have an announced
release date yet, and as of late 2018, Foxx
was still looking for the right distributor
for the project.
Perry Mason
Back in 2016 it was reported that Downey would
star in a new miniseries from HBO following
a reimagined version of criminal defense attorney
Perry Mason from the CBS television series
starring Raymond Burr which ran from 1957
to 1966.
"You didn't kill Thompson.
But you did, Mr Wells!"
"Yes!
I killed Ned Thompson!"
Set in 1930s Los Angeles, the miniseries is
set to focus on the character's origin story.
When the project was initially announced,
True Detective creator Nic Pizzolatto was
also onboard to write the miniseries.
Things have changed significantly in the last
three years, but Perry Mason is still happening.
Downey is still very much involved, though
he will no longer star in the series.
Downey has instead stepped back into the role
of executive producer on the series alongside
his wife and producing partner Susan Downey.
The Americans star Matthew Rhys has instead
been cast in the title role.
The Footprint Coalition
He may be done playing Tony Stark, but Robert
Downey Jr.'s journey as a world-changing mogul
may be just beginning.
Downey appeared at Amazon's ReMARS conference
in June 2019 and, in the midst of a 20-minute
talk about his life, career, and interest
in technology and the environment, he announced
a major new initiative.
In April of 2020 Downey will launch the Footprint
Coalition, an organization that will work
to improve the environment using advanced
technologies like artificial intelligence
and nanotechnology.
Basically, Downey is playing Tony Stark in
real life.
He said during the announcement,
"Between robots and nanotechnology, we could
clean up the planet significantly, if not
totally, in 10 years."
At this point we still don't know exactly
what the Footprint Coalition will do first,
or what technologies it will use to achieve
its goals.
At the moment, the organization is little
more than a sparse website with an option
to sign up for a newsletter.
But if RDJ is involved, it's likely to make
plenty of headlines in the years to come.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.